IEIN VALDEZ: Hi, I'm Iein
Valdez, a developer advocate
with Google App Engine.
I'm here to show you how easy
it is to get up and running
with a Python application.
So what I've done is I've
installed the Python app
engine, SDK.
Locally I'm running
it on a Mac.
It also is easy to install
on Windows or on Linux.
So it's a small download, and
you should be up and running
in a few minutes.
So let's go ahead and start the
Google App Engine Launcher.
And what we're going to do is
create our first project.
So in the bottom, left-hand
corner we can create a new
application.
And let's go ahead and name
our application iein-demo.
I'm going to go ahead
and click Create.
And what that has done is it has
created a starter project
for us with some sample code.
So let's go ahead
and click Edit.
And we see here that it has got
four files set up for me,
app.yaml, which is where
my application
configuration's set up.
We can look through
this real quick.
I have my application name.
We see I'm running in Python.
And I have two handlers set up,
one to serve a favicon for
me, and the second is to route
all other incoming requests to
that main.py Python script.
So let's take a look at
the main.py script.
And this is a very simple
web-app handler that literally
prints out hello world.
So let's go ahead
and run this.
And let's take a look and
see what it looks like.
So we're going to go back
here, click Run.
And the nice thing about the
app engine SDK is that it
mimics our cloud environment
locally on your desktop.
So you can see what
it's like to run
your application locally.
So I have the application
running.
I'm going to click the Browse
button, which is going to
launch my browser and
point it locally.
And we see here, I've got hello
world, which is great.
But now I want to make some
changes and iterate.
And let's see what that
experience is like.
So we're going to go back here
into my text editor.
And let's make a couple
of changes.
We'll just say, hello world,
I love the cloud.
I'll click Save. We can go back
into our browser, hit
Refresh, and you see that the
code is refreshed with the
latest changes that I've made.
So it makes it really easy
to make changes to your
application and test them.
So now, let's get
this application
running in the cloud.
I'm ready for business.
I'm ready to have millions
of users hit my little
application.
Let's see what that's like.
So we'll go into the App
Engine Launcher.
And you'll see in the right hand
corner here, we have this
Deploy button.
So I'm going to go ahead
and click that.
And I have my credentials
already set up.
And so what this is doing is
taking the code that is on my
desktop and packaging it up
and shipping it off to
Google's data centers and
servers and essentially
loading it up there.
So it will package up any
images, any static files,
everything that I need to
get up and running.
So we see here that now
it has essentially
pushed the data up.
The deployment was successful.
So now let's go ahead and hit
the website and see if it's up
and running.
So my app is called
iein-demo.appspot.com.
There we go.
Hit Refresh a couple times.
We can see that it's
actually running.
And now I've basically taken my
simple Python application
from my desktop, pushed it to
Google's cloud, and it's now
auto-scaled.
And millions and millions of
users are able to hit that
application.
So it's really easy to get up
and running, especially on the
Python runtime.
Take a look and get your first
app up and running.
Thanks much.